hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to citizen burger disorder
game recommended to me by you guys and I
don't know what the hell is going on in
these pictures but apparently it's a
multiplayer online very strange burger
management sim of some sort because I
don't really know what the hell's going
on
all I know is that I have options to use
my arms and pick up things and make
burgers rat don't steal my money that's
my money you go in the money thing
whatever though that is rat rat Rattus
don't make me cook you into it don't
steal my money hey give me my money back
rat bastard come here you hey don't take
that are you yo come here come here come
here go here I got two rats now what do
you think you're doing your rats
stealing all my food you know what now
get my my my I will cook you and serve
you to a customer if you don't behave
yourself yeah I took the rest of my
money your damn rats get out of here
with your stupid faces okay so I got one
burger with two buns one meat one Green
two red nipple thingies and bacon
probably two bacon so he did gently
take one of these hair patties throw it
on there oh that's a sadist some good
maybe I don't know but then the other
one is a double god who's putting these
orders in oh the hell's running my front
end that's not a euphemism oh there we
go sorry about the rest of the baddies
ha okay this one looks pretty close to
maybe done maybe yeah
oh it's stick sides handy that okay well
I've had lattice I like to grab from the
bottom of the stack because I'm weird
do I have to cook these I think maybe
that was a yes that sounded like the
acknowledgement sizzle of a yes oh god
damn it I was supposed to have a cheese
in between those uh you'll never know
it's a goddamn nightmare
no not you know don't do flips it's not
for burger-flipping time there yeah that
looks fantastic put that over there and
you're done
but you and you want a plate I won't be
good go heal up okay get the hell back
on that play you son of a [ __ ] don't
even think about real okay you are
[ __ ] I hate you you're on the same
order you on the same plate deal with it
goddamn it the plate got buried in the
goddamn counter all right fine I'll take
you on separate plates cuz you're just
needy little pieces of ass is this yours
yeah there you go what no don't throw my
money on the floor that's yours I guess
thank you
I don't care if you didn't like it god
damn it who the hell's supposed to be
able to do this I think this is supposed
to be a multiplayer game and you're
supposed to actually have other people
here when you play the game but I don't
know what the hell I'm doing hey hey
what do you think you're doing lady huh
you think you want a pair oh you think
you want a burger huh kudos Wabash husky
I miss Sheila you're out here you're out
here you're unruly and unwelcome I don't
care if you're unhappy I just want to
hold you close no never mind I want to
rotate you slowly because I guess we're
dancing now is this romantic I'm not
sure if this is what romance means why
you're out of here you're out of here
okay goodbye dildo lady hey whoa whoa
hey Oh who's gonna make something
burgers ass [ __ ] there's a lot behind
okay so I put the call out on Twitter
for anyone who wants to play this game
with me I don't know how it's gonna work
or if anyone's actually gonna be able to
join my server but I told them that I'm
mark emu and whoever wants make burgers
with me can join my burger Empire we can
take over the world
lady you seem very upset of the fact
that I'm doing this with my mind maybe
you could ease up a step oh come on rats
alright you know what I mad about enough
of you I am literally gonna cook you up
and serve you on a burger you were being
stupid oh you are cooking oh my god he
does not like that he is twitching like
nobody's business
this is somewhat horrible but at least
he has cheese he seems to be a bit
browner no no no no you still alive too
bad eh you're going on a burger yeah oh
my god that worked it worked oh it
worked
Oh get right get get fit right okay I
got a dress you up real good yay Oh
someone's gonna eat this and someone is
hopefully gonna pay for this hopefully
not because that would be horrible but
here we go anyway
are you happy mr. speaker are you happy
let's give you to this lady who didn't
like my buck you oh my god you ate it
oh there's blood on the go god that's
horrible that's horrible but thank you
for the money alright so I joined
another server and I've told people on
Twitter to join me here I'm probably
gonna okay nevermind okay well I joined
another person server I wonder how long
this one's gonna last before it crashes
horribly I'm sure there's gonna work out
great
hello y'all look like zombies
all the supplies are neatly strewn about
on the floor exactly what we needed
this business has got to go great the
perfect burger
who's hungry are you looking Greer are
they for you Lenny for you how's your
there big man
oh you like that I know you did yep ha
ha all right I got disconnected by the
server oh ok I'm back in apparently whoa
hello hi
you look very organized I'm going to
help you I am also going to help burger
we're gonna burger together cuz we're
burger buddies go my excuse me sorry I
just want to help trying to help helping
I'm helping
he doesn't look too good no no don't
look at me don't look at me hey-ho
hey-ho what you gonna do hey ho hi would
you like to play are we going to have
fun time is this how we do ha ha ha is
that fun is this fun for you and me and
friend I I didn't do it it was him it
was him over it was him go new guy the
one with the rat and a very grim
disposition good yes
no no you're here cook you hold you make
sure that it's screaming stops I am
burning that I think it's burnt enough
it's good it's good yeah
ok let me just get a pun there we go
that's dial that's normal I'd say that's
a healthy helping of normal I would wait
is what it is and now the rat is gone
ok now you're just making a mess to make
a mess what are you doing hey you what
are your names sir
space spindle ash Hey Oh what you gonna
do are we dancing I thought we were
having a moment spindle - come back
please well return my affections whoa
you are
please tell me someone is actually
holding that that's to stop floating
there
that's funny there oh you're an
amalgamation of many Berger that is good
that is go okay this is not good cuz I
can kind of see it oh okay this is not
what I would call normal I don't even
know what the rats are doing yeah whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
excuse me that is goddamn terrifying
what the hell is wrong with you
ooh looky there might be done think I
might be done
I can't even scare you what are you
looking at
you're not Schmidty okay something
horrible is going on right in front of
me right now okay that that happened
you're touching me right now and it's
very weird but that's okay you do your
thing just go yeah thank you very much
so anyway you want to play it links in
the description get some friends make
some chaos why not
it's kind of fun so anyway thank you
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye until
now noise ever eyes oh okay okay okay
okay back up act like
and I made me blow my own tree I will
already go no no oh I'm dead